you better not promise things to Earth
Day people that you can't deliver Earth
Day people can be very unforgiving happy
Earth Day everybody that most sacred
feast in our secular liturgical calendar
when people worship a pagan nature
goddess in a holiday that was
established by a man best known for
murdering and composting his girlfriend
you can't say that he wasn't consistent
to mark this year's Earth Day we will be
going back through some of the most
important pieces of wisdom from the
patron saint of Earth Day this clip is
brought to you by geniusell or from
genucel in just a little bit for now
though let's get to those words of
wisdom from
and now the weather forecast with Greta
tunberg
that was the weather with Greta tunberg
it's not nice
I'm gonna have to have talking to with
my producers because you're not allowed
you are not allowed to do anything other
than worship at the altar of Greta trust
me I speak from experience if you ever
raise any questions about
the entire Global left following this
troubled individual if you ever raise
any questions about the exploitation of
this person when she was a bit young it
will not work out well for you there is
no Planet B there is no Planet blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah this is not
about some expensive politically correct
green Act of bunny hugging or blah blah
blah blah blah blah over 50 percent of
all our CO2 emissions have occurred
since 1990 and a third since 2005. if
this is what they consider to be climate
action then we don't want it they invite
Cherokee young people to meetings like
this to pretend that they are listening
to us
but they are not they are clearly not
listening to us she actually makes a
pretty good point there I don't believe
what I'm hearing she summarized most of
what she has to say in those earlier
statements blah blah blah blah
blah blah that that is pretty much the
substance of what she has to say but
she's right here when she says that
she's just trotted out as a mascot by
the corporations and by the global
liberal Elite that's totally true when
they talk about we need to get to Net
Zero and all the emissions and none of
these people are afraid of the sun
monster none none of these people
believe it Greta thunberg might actually
believe it herself she may have been
suckered into this nonsense and so one
could see why she'd become really
frustrated if she really thought that
the world were going to end two years
ago or whenever they said the world is
supposed to end but the people who Trot
her out as their favorite mascot and pet
they don't believe it and they are liars
and they are extremely cynical and
they've exploited her so if I were her
I'd be pretty angry too now sure you
could go to Brazil or Colombia get crazy
stuff done to your face to look younger
why would you do that when you could
just use genucel people are raving about
genucel products people like Claire who
says I absolutely love geniusell my skin
feels so good Tighter and younger with a
more even tone and I've been using it
only for a week nothing works like
genius Outlet's family recipe that's
been perfected over 20 years by
compounding pharmacist who works in
small batches and with only safe natural
cruelty free ingredients with warmer
weather just around the corner and our
friends at genu cell including two
spring time Essentials in their most
popular package now is the time to order
you get the ultra retinol and the Dark
Spot Corrector try genucel's most
popular package for 70 off at
genucel.com Knowles all orders are
upgraded to free shipping and every
subscription order includes a
complimentary spring spa box with three
spot Essentials three free gifts plus
free shipping I count that as four free
gifts go to geniusell.com
Knowles Greta wrote quote top climate
scientist is warning that climate change
will wipe out all of humanity unless we
stop using fossil fuels over the next
five years and that was written in 2018
so by my
calculations It Was Written in June of
2018 so I guess we've still got a little
bit of time and and actually in Greta's
defense the climate scientist and the
the journalists worded this in a way
such that they're not saying that the
world would end in five years
they're saying that we would get to the
point of no return
Humanity would be extinguished
eventually if we don't stop using fossil
fuels within five years huh so they're
really smart about this they always set
the date of Extinction at some point in
the vague future but they always create
a really specific point of no return
that we have to hit I said well you know
we've reached that point of no return
but if we want to
ameliorate the conditions of Destruction
maybe now we just do whatever we just do
whatever the libs
demand how come you never protest Saudi
Arabia or Russia you only protest
Western Energy why have you never
criticized Vladimir Putin or OPEC
yeah I've never done that never ever
will you do so now will you condemn OPEC
energy
and then
she won't she won't answer the questions
answer the question she just dismisses
them which is probably the smart way to
do it because it's not as though Greta
thunberg is a Grassroots kind of
activist or movement Greta sunberg has
been astroturfed into the public
imagination she undertook these very
expensive campaigns that were very well
funded and well organized she took that
sailboat remember in that first trip
across to call attention to the
environmental crisis even though it
would have been far better for the
environment had she just taken an
airplane over to America instead of
taking this boat with multiple people
taking multiple airplanes to create this
publicity stunt so she doesn't need
these moments Her Image is straight out
of Hollywood so if some some
conservative journalist comes up to her
and asks her a question she can just
laugh it off
she knows that the people who are really
projecting Her Image which are some of
the most powerful people in the world
that video comes from the world economic
Forum in Davos those people will make
sure that her image is just fine okay
next one my message is that we'll be
watching you
this is all wrong
I shouldn't be up here
I should be back in school on the other
side of the ocean
yet you all come to us young people for
hope
how dare you
you have stolen my dreams in my
childhood with your empty words
people are suffering
people are dying
entire ecosystems are collapsing we are
in the beginning of a mass extinction
and all you can talk about is money and
fairy tales of Eternal economic growth
how dare you
not a persuasive performance right
at the time it just read as scripted and
I didn't it didn't really come off but
let's say that it were sincere you would
have a great deal of sympathy for her
because this girl like all of these
younger people have been told that the
world is going to end and I include
myself even in those younger people I
include people who are even older than
me we have been told in this country for
50 years now that global warming is
going to kill everybody for global
cooling I guess is what they first
worried about 50 years ago or
overpopulation or any of this other
nonsense and they've said it's the
greedy awful terrible people who are who
are doing it and you have no hope you're
all going to die and so if you're a
gullible person or if you're just a
trusting person you would be very upset
about that and in a way they have
stolenial dreams and your childhood
because they they've made you dedicate
yourself to something that's just
nonsense it's just window dressing for
liberal political Elites who want to
take more power and need need an arm
again style excuse to do so and so in a
way they have stolen her childhood now
they've paid her pretty well for it
Greta thundberg has done pretty well for
herself probably better than she would
have had she stayed in school and gotten
an education at least financially I'm
sure she's done much better but she has
been persuaded to devote her life to
nonsense
thank you very much
Trump just doesn't even acknowledge her
that's probably good damn it feels good
to be a gangster I guess she wasn't a
child at that point she's a bit older
but children are supposed to be seen and
not heard in quite many cases especially
when their ideas are just very wrong and
and had Greta been been more inclined
toward pursuing her education she she
probably would have been able to discern
truth from falsehood and would not have
been so suckered in by these
fear-mongering liberal Elites who will
exploit anybody to take a little bit
more power happy Earth Day
try not to get murdered or composted by
any of those Charming environmentalists
today see you next time
lies on our doorstep but